okay let's talk about afghanistan let's
um this will be a fun conversation yeah
uh so we're journalists yes we're
journalists and we know exactly this is
100 facts everything we're going to give
you is verified facts it's a pretty
simple situation too very simple yeah um
okay so
we've pulled out of afghanistan uh
the taliban has taken control
of the country i mean they took like a
week yeah they are so fast very good
these talibans very good very good put
them in the olympics and um
it is uh it's it's here's the here's the
situation that's really tricky just
seeing the like the the reaction from
people
there's no good solution here correct we
went in here bush went went in there
after 9 11. it was disgusting it was
stupid it was [ __ ] up we should have
never been there at all okay we've
occupied this place for 20 years okay
there's no solution
we either stay there we continue to
occupy it forever yeah right or we pull
out and we go we [ __ ] up now we have
to have some responsibility for the
people that we're leaving right like we
[ __ ] up the situation so i think we
should be responsible to take every
single person that wants to leave back
if they want to go to america they want
to go to somewhere else we work out some
sort of situation where they can go to
other places and we work out with the
you know one of our allies maybe they
want to go live there and they're
willing to accept them again i haven't
worked out this this theory but i do
believe that's our responsibility to
protect those people especially if we
went in there and [ __ ] the whole thing
you're talking about afghanistan
afghani citizens afghani people that are
just living there like anybody that's
going to be [ __ ] by this situation
could potentially be killed jailed uh
have their livelihood taken from anybody
who wants to leave we've done this with
other people in the past like we did it
with the
the the people um
the hmong people
right in vietnam i think we did it with
uh a lot of vietnamese people we did it
with cambodians we did a lot of people
from that region in the vietnam war he's
like yo you sided with us now shit's
about to be [ __ ] up for y'all if you
want to come move to houston you're good
to go right
um
i think we have that responsibility for
these people and it looks like we're not
going to take it but it's really [ __ ]
up and just leave them there that being
said
um
i think that we've been misled in terms
of like how much
uh we prepared them to fight back
against the taliban
like i was i was speaking to a guy who's
there
right now and uh he basically was like
yeah they were not like they didn't
really train the army here
and when you think about it that makes
sense what are we really gonna do train
them so they're just as good as the us
army
is that what we want do we want
high-tech weapons high-tech training
zero reliance on us what do you think
the next step is get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah well that's what happened with
the taliban the first time right they
trained them to fight against russia in
the cold war and then they became
taliban took over the country and now
their threat to national security in
2001. and now what does the taliban have
all the weapons on the weapons yeah but
wasn't that the story though it was like
oh we'll go in like we'll teach them how
to fight and teach them how to be
self-sustaining against the taliban then
we'll leave and then american occupation
will work to try to impact yeah that
sounds great it's communism it sounds
great in theory but in reality you know
it wins wars as weapons right that was
the story not [ __ ] karate
i mean yeah
so uh it's a it's obviously a very
tricky situation and um
it just really sucks man because it
exposes what a monumental fuck-up that
we did we went in there we [ __ ] [ __ ]
up simple as that and there's tons of
conspiracy theories going around like
one thing that i kind of thought of and
i don't know how real this [ __ ] is and i
know actually i was doing a little bit
more research on this absolute [ __ ]
so maybe it's just maybe it's just like
a convenient timing but i do not find it
weird that
the second these pharmaceutical
companies can make a lot of money off
the vaccine they no longer need the
poppy fields for all their opioid uh
drugs right right the oxycontins and
these type of things and you know
afghanistan has like the largest
producer of poppy opioid opium poppy in
the world right so it's like oh now we
have money to make on the vaccines well
we don't need that [ __ ] no we can leave
afghanistan the taliban was like burning
down poppy fields in like the 90s
they were like trying to destroy them
so it's like of course we're going to be
in there and of course we're going to
need something to offset all the money
that we're spending over there so if
we're spending a trillion dollars or
with however many billion dollars a year
we're spending to prop up this country
well we're gonna need something out of
it oh what do we have okay these natural
resources poppy fields i think they're
like the the biggest lithium provider in
the world like it's the uh saudi arabia
of lithium i think people describe it so
obviously there's these natural
resources that people really want and uh
we really want and um
we just removed ourselves and it's just
a really i don't know i just i just kind
of feel sad about it man i just feel sad
because it's almost like we're setting
it up for the okie doke right it's
almost like we get out of there and now
we're going to go back to like how
horrible the taliban is and how horrible
islam is and and how horrible
terrorism is and we need to get back
there to make sure we protect them and
and secure them like you already see the
narrative start to go right it's like
which is how they got us the first time
yeah that's why because you said it was
we should have never been
uh we should have never gone there in
the first place but i remember 2001 i'm
sure you remember very well being like
oh it was we had very good intelligence
the taliban we have the video of bin
laden saying it was him so we got to go
in there and get them out of here
they're a threat to u.s security yeah
and then once you went there it became
hey we need to keep the people of
afghanistan safe and we were like why
you're just sending troops over there i
remember every presidential candidate
saying i'm going to pull out i'm going
to pull the troops out now we pulled the
troops out we saw how quickly he fell
apart and now i think a lot of people
are acting like why the [ __ ] do we pull
out whereas all the time i remember
before this we were like why are we
still there
so it is a flip i think on our parts
where we're just kind of
hey i'm not going to be happy either way
why are we there for 20 years and then
the second we leave why would we ever
leave
yeah because that's the thing with the
people who say who are upset that we
left is like what do you want do you
want occupation forever you understand
our troops over there over and over and
over yeah because we don't like losing
our troops and the chances of losing
them there are way higher yeah i don't
like imperialism or not right that's the
thing though especially the media like
just flipped on him so quick yeah
apparently bison's been pretty like
anti-like iraqi uh intervention and like
iraq or like afghani intervention for a
long time yeah apparently he was opposed
to vietnamese intervention also oh wow
apparently he told the president at the
time like he was like a super the young
senator he was like yeah this is a lost
cause let's get out of here so he's been
trying to do this for a long time and
the media was like yeah let's get out
let's get out bro like seeing the media
start to spin narratives is so funny
even this [ __ ]
botched face [ __ ] nancy pelosi is out
here like they're already pushing the
propaganda about
feminism and
lgbtq acceptance right like it is
honestly brilliant the way the
military-industrial complex has used
feminism
and
rights
as propaganda for middle east
intervention it is genius they're like
who are the people that we need to
convince
to go oppress brown people out there in
other parts of the world who are the
people in america that would give the
push back to that you tell conservatives
like yo we got to protect america
they're like we're in there you want to
protect the flag let's go these liberals
you can't say that because they don't
[ __ ] love the flag as much they've
been anti-war for a long time yeah
we're back in vietnam they're the ones
pushing back we don't want intervention
so you need to tap into something that
they really care about right you need to
tap into the groups that are oppressed
and that you want to fight for so now
you've got
women's rights activists right you have
gay rights activists going we need to go
save women we need to go save gays out
there i've seen some blm stuff people
were like yo like black lives matter
there's black people in afghanistan blah
blah
so it's so genius they just go
nancy pelosi tweeted something the other
day this [ __ ] [ __ ] she goes uh she
goes oh it's disgusting and so sad what
the taliban is going to be doing to
these women just snatching them up and
keeping them as sex slaves as they go
and take back the country of afghanistan
we can't let this happen which it is
which they're going to do but we only
care about the sex slave [ __ ] when it
happens in countries with natural
resources like there are i was tweeting
this the other day there's literally
countries where they chop the clits off
of girls and they don't have natural
resources so we don't care there's a
civil war in ethiopia right now we do
not care no one knows about that no
one's talking about like ethiopians are
chopping each other up as we speak
so it's like it's so it's such [ __ ]
and it's shocking that that the extreme
like leftist liberals haven't given any
pushback to this i'm actually really
shocked you don't hear anything from
bernie sanders like bernie sanders talks
all this [ __ ]
right about like the billionaire class
where's the talk about like raytheon
where does it talk about the
military-industrial complex where does
it talk about the military
like where's aoc and it makes me feel
like oh you're a part of this yeah
you're still a part of this system you
don't operate outside the system like i
want bernie to be like why are you using
gay rights and women's rights as a proxy
to go there and basically
destroy people's lives and take
resources from these countries in the
middle east yeah but that's like all the
things that we argue about are sort of
like the negotiables those are like the
small rocks that are like yeah this is
the culture where we go back and forth
about it and like we try to earn ships
here and there but as far as american
imperialism goes we're not [ __ ] any
of that yeah like every politician
whether you're left right center like
you are in favor of american imperialism
in in terms of like your operation
within the political machine and is that
well it depends that one girl that
everybody hated the ethiopian chick
uh johann omar yeah omar she gave tons
of pushback to american intervention
anywhere yeah and then people are like
you're not even american that's the
thing there's only that there was one
congresswoman that objected to
uh afghani intervention after 2001.
bernie voted against it like
historically a lot in two in 2001 there
was only one senator at the time that
went against it was a democrat from
california and just let me clarify i
believe that bernie's against it but
he cries about bezos not paying any
taxes cries every single day about uh
what other companies maybe like elon
musk cries about warren buffett the
billionaire class
billionaire classic i don't know if
that's necessarily objectionable like
i'm cool if he does it that's fine
they're not making the [ __ ] money
well i guess you could say their
companies are but they're not dictating
policy
like these
bomb makers that that doesn't
necessarily go toward american
imperialism to use mark's turn from
earlier right like that doesn't help
keep the empire going as much as we got
to keep these people up i guess what i'm
trying to say is like i think he knows
where the bread is buttered and i think
he knows things that just aren't gonna
ah yeah man i don't know i mean you
would think that there would be a little
bit of a conversation that's a valid
point let's or that maybe they pay taxes
and he's okay with that as long as
raytheon's paying taxes that's all he
wants is tax dollars and then you can go
take resources from wherever the [ __ ]
you want you can start endless wars in
these different places i can't i would
imagine he wants those tax dollars to go
toward universal health care or
something can i ask you a question let's
assume all this is true and everything
at the end of the day we're not [ __ ]
with american imperialism we're going to
keep our empire running is that the best
thing for us
our lives
in this room all better because america
does all this [ __ ] and then we kind of
get to act like we're above it somehow
i'm going to reap the benefits
a friend of mine sat down with the ceos
of uh
of raytheon right once for this is a
while back i won't name any names or
anything like that but like and asked
him it was like you hear all this
[ __ ] about the military they didn't
say [ __ ] you hear all this criticism
about the military industrial complex
and like starting wars so for profit
how do you guys feel about that
and they said candidly to him
um
missiles don't sell themselves
their
commodity right their their
product yeah is missiles yeah right
you need a purpose for missiles right
right if you sell horse and carriages or
hordes and buggies or whatever like that
and now we got cars
you're out of business baby
if we don't have war we don't have
conflict right they're out of business
those ceos i wonder if their [ __ ] job
is to make sure there's some conflict
and i feel like this is i don't know
like whenever people talk about the
elites to me that's what it comprises
it's like corporate executives like
primarily within like war industries yes
the media and the politicians they
execute right they're bidding and so
like they can go to the media and be
like hey like look at this crazy story
this is kicking up i'll send you this
footage like these pictures this video
it's going to really scare people it'll
be good for your ratings and it'll also
be good for us and it'll be good be good
for the politicians that save the day
everybody wins yes except for the people
that are getting imperialized yes
yes
you